ouais
bonjour à tous bienvenue devant les
théâtres départementaux pour cette
nouvelle édition du toto total au
festival de jeunes publics
et pour nous parler d'un des spectacles
bonjour alors éric toi tu es auteur
compositeur de imad hoballah bill alors
déjà c'est quoi il m'a gobet la bile
explique emma gobal habile c'est un
spectacle de théâtre visuel et de danse
aérienne qui est proposé aux enfants dès
le plus jeune âge
mais pour nous il n'y a pas de trop de
limites même si dans les salles comme ça
c'est proposer car après trois quatre
ans et c'est un solo pluridisciplinaire
donc à une interprète qui pouvait pas
être là aujourd'hui
céline bosc qui est sur scène et qui
mélange de la danse aérienne du jeu
clownesque puis ce qu'on appelle le
théâtre visuel ce qui a pas de texte
mais par l'utilisation d'accessoires des
positions du corps on raconte quelque
chose par l'image fait au plateau
et dans ces cas là quand on fait appel à
l'imaginaire sur les enfants ça se
déclenche tout de suite c'est quoi c'est
plus facile pour des enfants
je sais pas si c'est plus facile pour
des enfants en tout cas c'est un
incontournable dire que quand on
s'adresse à un public d'enfants
la dimension émotionnelle la sincérité
de l'interprète sont très très
importants donc nous mais la priorité là
dessus au départ
et ensuite les bains une histoire
comment dire de mise en disposition une
fois qu'ils sentent que quelque chose de
sincère on peut circuler pu raconter des
histoires racontées des situations
est ce que ça veut dire que quand ils
sortent chaque enfant à asson son
interprétation de ce qu'il a vu presque
ben oui mais c'est un peu le cas de tout
le monde quand on voit un film ont des
fois où tu as vu à la fin j'ai cru que
c'était et on n'est pas toujours plus
d'accord sur l'est tout cas quand quand
les assemblages sont complexes et où
vous vous justement un tas de possibles
eh bien là c'est à chacun de s'y
projeter et puis de construire son
ressenti par rapport au spectacle comme
ça
comment vous mélangez tous les arts le
cir que le fas comment vous faites pour
ça hein
est-ce que c'est plus facile avec du vin
jeune public justement de tout mélanger
entre guillemets c'est une question nous
dans la compagnie on ne se pose pas la
question des jeunes publics comme une
figure de style ou commun disons que
quand on fait ouais tant que musicien
que je fais de la musique je fais de la
musique je me dis pas tu fais de la
musique pour les enfants
il se trouve que c'est plutôt sur
effectivement l'adresse l'adresse au
jeune public les enjeux
qu'est-ce qu'on veut leur raconter c'est
là que ça colore notre proposition mais
par contre dans nos disciplines est bon
on fait de la musique comme on fait de
la musique situation ont fait du tissu
aérien comment on fait du tissu aérien
dans toute situation là c'est le toutes
ces disciplines à pour nous c'est son
boîte à outils qu'on utilise aussi pour
ça aussi qu'on utilise 20 disciplines
différentes c'est parce que pour évoquer
évoqué évoqué certaines images certains
enjeux on va utiliser des disciplines
différentes et c'est cet assemblage là
qu'il fait la proposition globale
donc pas de limite d'âge tout le monde
est le bienvenu
vous avez compris le message pousser
cette porte et venez voir imago balle
habile au théâtre départemental de champ
fleuri
à bientôt merci